If you want to hear my theory about what the
heck is going on here -- why is this is Jack-o-lantern
in the fishtank? -- then stick around to the
end of this video.
Welcome back to Things You Missed.
Earlier this week we talked about the trailer
for the new Halloween movie.
If you haven't seen that video click on over
here to check it out.
And in the comments for that video you guys
had some excellent points that I didn't touch
on in the first video.
In the original Halloween , the first guy
Michael kills in 1978 is this mechanic from
Phelps Garage.
Dr. Loomis finds the hospital gown in the
bushes and we pull out to see the guy has
been killed, his corpse is in the bushes and
his clothes have been taken.
So that's how Michael got his iconic garb.
Facestabber51 brought this up in the comments
and it made me realize something about the
new trailer, where we see this scene taking
place at an auto service center.
The British guy goes in and finds a body in
a puddle of blood.
He appears to be the mechanic and he's in
his underwear.
Not only is this paying tribute to John Carpenter's
Halloween, but it tells us that Michael seems
to be retracing his steps from all those years
ago.
That brings me to another comment, which theorizes
that Michael's rampage in old Halloween, was
never about going after Laurie, but rather
reliving the night he killed his sister Judith.
And I agree and disagree with this.
He does seem to be targeting Laurie, ever
since he sees her drop off that key at the
Myers house for her father, who is a realtor
who is trying to sell the house, but he can't
because everyone in town thinks it's haunted.
And let's face it, it kind of looks like ****.
Because from that point, he's watching her
in school, following her around town, and
turning up at the house she babysits that
night.
The part I do agree with, which is a great
point, is the idea that Michael tries to recreate
the circumstances of Judith's murder when
he kills Annie.
Both start with seeing the victim undressed
from outside, he kills both with the knife
and then moves Annie to the bed under Judith's
tombstone to complete his recreation.
So my point is, if 1978 was Michael Myers's
recreation of 1963, then maybe 2018 is a recreation
of 1978, starting with him killing a mechanic
for his clothes, stealing the mask, doing
the ghost sheet thing, and this time, trying
not to let Laurie Strode get away.
We don't know how Michael gets his mask back
in this movie, or even if it is the very same
mask at all, but a couple of you theorized
that he gets his old mask from this guy.
Some of you think he's the new head psychiatrist
at Smith's Grove, some say he's even related
to Dr. Loomis while others see say he's just
a documentarian.
But many of you noticed if you pause right
here, it's actually his head being bashed
into the bathroom stall door.
So Michael probably takes him out to steal
back the mask.
And maybe this location is Phelps Garage, which is only referenced on this side of this truck in the first one.
In the last video I said that the bathroom
scene was a callback to H20 where the woman
gets attacked, but Joshua Wilson brings up
a good point, he never actually attacked her,
he just scared her and stole her car.
Someone else brought up another possible H20
reference, that being a waist high shot of
Michael doing this little knife flip move.
I'm not sure if that's exclusive to H20 and
I'm not about to rewatch them all to find
out.
I'll just take your word for it, it's a nice
little find..
OK, I love this next one, suggested by Lowbudget
Skitz.
In the clip where Laurie yells at the trick-or-treaters
to get inside there's a quick glimpse of two
kids running away wearing Silver Shamrock
masks from Halloween 3: Season of the Witch.
If you haven't seen it, the masks are a major
plot-point of Halloween 3, so this is a really
cool split-second reference.
Moving on, I had previously said I thought
this photo could be Tommy Doyle and many of
you said you thought it was young Michael
Myers.
Those of you who said that were correct, and
here's why.
This file is probably Michael's file at Smith's
Grove where he was a patient starting at age
6.
This white wall looks like something out of
the sanitarium, not a house.
The kid in the photo has shorts on, which
Tommy does not at the end of Halloween.
Michael is initially taken in wearing this
clown costume so there's a good chance he
had shorts underneath.
Another correction you guys made was on this
diagram.
For some reason I read this as one slash across
the neck and one across the shoulder, but
looking at it again it’s clearly one slash
that stretches the neck and shoulder.
Plus I looked back and Laurie never actually
gets a cut on her neck, so this is an injury
report on Annie, not Laurie.
Annie gets strangled and gets her throat slit
in the car when she’s about to go pick up
her boyfriend, and we can see the result of
her injuries later after Michael relocates
her to the bed.
John Archangel wants to know Do you think
Laurie finally got with Ben Tramer?
And if you don’t remember, Ben Tramer is
the guy Laurie has a crush on who’s mentioned
but not seen in the first movie, and killed
off early in Halloween II....
BUT Halloween II doesn’t exist in this continuity,
so there’s a chance they got together.
And Laurie does have grandkids now so you
never know.
I mean, I hope for her sake that it works
out for Laurie and Ben in this continuity
because they just haven’t had any luck in
any of the others, plus it would be a cool
throwaway line if someone mentioned that her
husband’s name was Ben or something like
that.
The most mysterious part of the trailer is
this Jack-o-lantern inside the fish tank.
I don’t think it’s just a Halloween decoration
for the fishes, I actually have a theory on
it.
I think this guy in the foreground, is actually
this guy, the cop.
So he’s coming to this house to investigate
a disturbance.
The chair’s been tipped over and there’s
blood on the floor.
This sheet ghost isn’t moving.
Either it’s Michael Myers hiding underneath
or a victim’s body that’s been covered
up.
Whatever the case may be, I think someone
tried to throw the pumpkin at Michael in self
defense, missed and it just ended up landing
in the fish tank.
But what do you think?
Do you think this is Michael?
Do you think it’s one of the victims?
Do you think this guy at the end of the trailer
is the real Michael, or just someone playing
a prank?
Let me know in the comments.
And if you’ve been enjoying all the new
videos lately, let me know my giving this
one a like.
There’s a lot more to talk about so let’s
keep the discussion going.
Make sure you’re subscribed to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week, ring that deathbell
for notifications and I’ll see you in the
next one.
Assuming we both survive.